Cmike: How's this arm coming along?
Jake: Phase two on the Bionic Arm build:
We've got all our paint dry, or already dried.
And now I'm applying this ind-
*crashing noises*
Jeez, Wren! You ruined all my audio!
I've got industrial strength Velcro that I'm using to secure
the pieces of crafty foam to the glove.
*riiip*
You can just do that
*slap*
and put it back on.
Cmike: Oh, that looks awesome!
Jake: Wire staples.
I took them, I painted them and then I bought some crafty wire at Michael's.
And now I'm stringing those through the glove to give it this knuckled effect.
And on the fingertips you'll have these looking like that.
I finished the arm! Got a little weathering.
Hopefully this will look pretty good from not too close on camera.
Supplies used:
Crafty foam,
crafty paint,
rivets,
lacing,
outside of a plastic cup,
black glove,
black sleeve,
and Velcro.
Pretty good for the limited amount of time I put into it.
And we're ready to shoot the video.
I got an interesting idea a few years back.
A neighbor that used to live in our building did etchings in acrylic.
he would light them with LED lights.
Put LED lights on the edge of acrylic, the etchings kinda glow.
So, you know,
If he had a red panel, a green panel, and a blue panel, and he layered them,
that effectively give you RGB pixels.
You can make any color you want.
He's named Corri after the company.
So, eventually I went onto Amazon, I bought three pieces of acrylic.
And three sets of RGB LEDs.
Put the red LEDs on one set
the green on another
and the blue on another.
And then I use a Dremel to go to town etching the whole thing.
So here we have all the colors of the rainbow by me etching on red, blue and green.
Let me show you what happens when I split this apart.
So you see I have the blues kinda etched here
reds kinda etched here
and the greens kinda there.
So when I put them together...
So you kinda have to back up to get the full effect here.
So I just did a little landscape etching.
And the next step is to go bigger.
I want to get a nice big piece of acrylic like this.
So if you guys have any ideas of something that would work with this crazy color scheme, let me know.
Crazy sunset with a laser bridge.
Pink tiger with green eyes.
Uhhhh an explosion....
with laser beams.
If it has lasers in it, pretty much guaranteed to work.